the median American worker doesn't do
manual labor anymore the average
American worker is not a ditch digger
but they're also not doing incredibly
high-end particle physics or data
science they are what you'd call
somewhat routine knowledge worker that
is right in the sweet spot of where
technology is making its greatest
inroads and a good example of that is a
tax preparer that's someone who has
mastered a very complicated American tax
code but they do the same thing over and
over they apply that code to an
individual person that's recently become
fairly easy to automate and automate
very well so now a lot of us find a $40
program like TurboTax completely
adequate for our needs that's great news
for two out of three constituencies
that's great news for us as consumers we
get very good tax advice at a lower
price point it's really good news for
the team at Intuit they've created a lot
of value they should be able to capture
some of that value the constituency
that's most negatively affected is the
body of tax preparers out there these
are full COO our actually above average
educated they've been to college they've
been to an advanced degree they've got a
CPA they've done the right thing they've
invested their human capital in an area
they thought would lead to a long and
productive career and all of a sudden
here comes a $40 piece of software
that's putting a lot of downward
pressure on their wages and the law has
been another pretty high prestige
well-paid highly educated profession
there is a lot of pressure in the legal
industry these days law school
applications not per capita but raw law
school applications are at their lowest
level since the 1970s there are a number
of reasons for that one of them is the
fact that if you're in a discovery
process right now and you want to figure
out what's in the other guy's documents
you no longer need to employ an army of
lawyers to sit around and read boxes
full of documents those boxes are now
electronic folders full of electronic
documents and we've got a category of
software called ediscovery where you
basically just tell it what you're
looking for hit a button and
milliseconds later you get back every
instance of that pattern if there's a
smoking gun in the documents it's very
likely to find
that the head-to-head comparisons that
were able to do between the results of
ediscovery and the results of that army
of lawyers sitting around in reading
documents indicate that the e-discovery
actually gives you higher quality
outcomes so a lot of these trends are
putting pressure not just on that
classic median American worker but even
on fairly highly educated well-paid ones
like law it's always been the case that
technology is an engine of what Joseph
Schumpeter called creative destruction
the simultaneous destruction of old
companies and industries and jobs and
tasks and the creation of new ones and
that's clearly going on right now we see
a lot of new creation of technologies
jobs industries and professions so data
scientist is a very new job description
this is not just a statistician with the
new business card these are people who
have really mastered a very diverse and
important body of skills and they're
bringing them together to take advantage
of the oceans of digital data that we
have and really tremendous amounts of
computational power not a job not a job
category that existed ten years ago but
one that's up there at the fairly high
end of the skill distribution it's a
pretty good example of this phenomenon
of skill-biased technical change
you